foreign
they're journalists their guests welcome
to the press conference we are very
delighted to welcome the president of
the European commission again here in
Italian
uh the Prime Minister Gaga isn't the
president of the European commission
Ursula from The Lion just concluded
bilateral meeting and will deliver
shorts remarks after that it is possible
for media to ask questions the press
conference is held in English with
simultaneous translation into Estonian
first prime minister gagalas the tour is
yours
members of the press it is my great
pleasure to welcome you here in Estonia
thank you for the good and thorough
discussions that we have had I'm glad
that we will be opening the dialing
digital Summit shortly that will focus
on how to build trusted connections and
trusted Partnerships and how to avoid
new dependencies a topic that has a
greater urgency giving the ongoing
Russian aggression
uh the embodiment of The Trusted
connectivity concept that Estonia has
introduced is the European Union's
global gateway something usually
personally have been leading I'm also
happy that I can take you to narwad and
today right on the external border of
the EU there we will launch estonia's
just transition plan that will help us
to deliver a green transition for the
people of itaveroma we will also visit
the narva border crossing point and the
grand home manufacturing a place where
our histories or the histories of our
families
meets you were lost in Estonia a year
ago and since then a lot has changed
most notably Russia waging a full-scale
war against Southern European country
and that has an effect on all of us
uh dear Ursula you have been on the
Forefront of the European uh response to
Russian aggression and also European
support to Ukraine you understand well
the Russian threats and what it means to
our common Security Commission has
translated your understanding into
strong policy proposals I thank you for
the leadership in building and upholding
the unity in the EU
Ukraine's success on the battlefield
means that we have been on the right
track and that we must make use of this
momentum it must be translated into ever
increasing and stronger support to
Ukrainian soldiers economy and its
people we all must do more so that
Ukraine can free its territories this is
the way towards peace
and as you have rightly said this is the
time for us to show resolve not
appeasement
the war is now far from over and
therefore also economic isolation and
pressure on Russia must continue
sanctions aim to dry up its War Machine
it is important that a compromise was
found on our additional EU sanctions
containing also price gap on Russian oil
Russia crimes including crimes of
aggression crimes against humanity and
possible genocide cannot remain
unpunished our Focus needs to be on how
to achieve accountability impunity
cannot be an option and we cannot forget
about the Ukrainian War refugees
Ukrainian refugees mostly women and and
children already form about 4.4 percent
of our population our message to the
European commission is that European
solution is needed to assist those
fleeing the war inside Ukraine as well
as to support the member states who are
providing shelter and protection to
large number of Ukrainian refugees I
would also like to thank the commission
for the work they have been doing in
this regard
next to the conventional war that the
Russia is waging on Ukraine and there's
also a hybrid War and the war on
information going on we must pay
attention to the stability of our
societies because Russia's long-term
interest is to divide us not among the
European member states but also within
our societies and this brings me to my
final point which is energy Russia has
demonstrated very clearly how energy can
be used as a weapon this means we need
to ensure the energy Security in Europe
and we need to work on different tracks
decreasing Energy prices ensuring the
security of Supply
diversification of energy sources and
ending our dependence on Russian
hydrocarbons boosting immense
Investments to deliver green energy
at the moment the most time sensitive
issue is to find common solutions to
reducing Energy prices this will work
only in case we find joint Solutions and
not fragment the uh EU single Market
we discussed it last week in Prague and
must continue with urgency here I also
turned to the commission for their
leadership
this winter may be hard but it is the
price we must pay to put the stop to
Russian aggression and its imperialistic
dream once and for all and the only way
to do this is to demonstrate unity and
strength thank you
thank you Prime Minister President of
the commission please thank you very
much and thank you very much dear Kaya
I'm glad to be here back in Tallinn
thank you very much for a very good
bilateral meeting which is basically uh
the continuation of our ongoing dialogue
the two of us have all the time
let me reflect on a few topics that you
have mentioned the first one is indeed
Ukraine
I must say Estonia is an important
player in our response to the Russian
aggression and I really thank you for
your determination and being so
steadfast and staunch we share the same
understanding of the threat that Putin
poses
and I really want to thank you also for
being one of the main driver what the
delivery of the eighth
um sanctions packages is concerned uh as
you said it always needs Unity but it
also needs member states like Estonia
who are driving the unity forward these
sanctions are biting we see by now the
effect on the Russian economy and we
will keep up the pressure to drain
Putin's War chest
what I also want to thank for is the
warmth with which the Estonian people
have opened their hearts and their homes
to Ukrainian Refugee this is outstanding
this will be never forgotten we support
as much as we can through flexibilizing
funds but the big gesture of human
solidarity is outstanding and I really
want to thank the Estonian people for
that we are in this together
the European Union is the most important
supporter of Ukraine together with the
United States since the beginning of the
war we have supported Ukraine
financially with as team Europe with up
to 19 billion euros this is not
including the military capability and
Equipment support which is mostly
bilateral between member states and
Ukraine but also supported by the
European peace facility financially
um we have been discussing not only what
we have done but also what has to be
done we have the goal that we will have
a stable predictable and flexible
funding for Ukraine in these difficult
months of war and of course we will be
looking at the short time recovery for
example now the winter coming up how we
can support Ukraine in repairing the
schools for the school children or
providing shelter this is a European
task on the European level to support
Ukraine with the internally displaced
people and this has been one of the
topics we have been discussing
moreover we address the need to be
vigilant regarding our external borders
and visa for Russian citizens we need
rigorous controls we will be at the
border this is why the European
commission provided guidance to Our
member states to strengthen Security
checks
we need also to be vigilant regarding
the protection of our critical
infrastructure what happened to North
stream one and two shows that we have to
be prepared for these new types of
threats
the commission has developed a
five-point plan to enhance the
resilience we will present and discuss
that at the digital Summit
and we will soon be present then with
recommendation for the member states how
to implement that and how to make it
happen on the ground
and then the second big topic was of
course the topic of energy
we have to protect European citizens
from Putin's war on energy Putin is
strongly manipulating the energy markets
it is because of Putin and his war that
the energy prices are high gas prices
are high electricity prices are high
that is the price he wants us to pay
but and that is uh how he tried to
divide Us in vain he has not been
successful he will not be successful
so we have taken many steps in the past
already to address the skyrocketing
crisis just to give you a figure we have
been able not only to get rid of Russian
coal overall but also till the end of
the year we will wind down Russian oil
to 10 of what we initially had and if
you look at the gas supply the biggest
Factor at the beginning of the war of
all imported gas Russia had 40 percent
now we are down to 7.5 percent within
seven months so these were enormous
efforts done successfully diverting away
from Russian fossil fuels towards
reliable suppliers and invest in
renewable energies that give us
independence
we have also been discussing together
how we look at the gas market overall
with the skyrocketing prices and indeed
we will come forward as a commission in
the next two weeks with proposals to
tame the energy prices and to tame the
electricity prices
the aim is to reduce the price to a
certain level without
endangering security of supply
but as I've said the best way Beyond
this immediate action to intervene on
the market and to limit the electricity
and energy prices the best way over time
to get rid of any kind of blackmail from
Russia is to accelerate the clean
transition in renewable energy and I
know that Estonia has everything it
takes to achieve this transition and the
European Union is of course here to
support you in this transition towards
renewable energy to give you not only
Independence but also to do the right
steps in case of our climate
finally we will travel to Nava this
afternoon to launch the just transition
plan for the edaviro region this is an
investment plan of 354 million euros
from the European Union to support the
Region's industrial transition and
change and to ensure that nobody is Left
Behind in that region
Russia's War has confirmed the need for
trusted partnership and trusted
connectivity indeed as you set the
global gateway strategy can help deliver
this so I'm very much looking forward to
the digital Summit and thank you for the
attention
thank you now it's possible for me to
ask questions please take your outlet
you're representing and please use
microphone and please also say who to
whom the question is addressed to you
and first up is Estonian National
broadcaster please
thank you uh Dharma myberg from Estonian
Broadcasting Company question to both of
you do you support International
Tribunal for war crimes in Ukraine
because victims need some kind of at
least partially Justice thank you yes we
strongly support
International tribunals for war crime it
has to be brought before the law from
the very beginning on we have supported
Ukraine in collecting the evidence that
is very important and of course to make
the case in the international criminal
court and to support the investigation
teams that are on a regular basis going
to Ukraine it is of utmost importance
that those who are responsible for these
crimes are held accountable this is the
basis of our rule of law and the
international rule of law
uh yes we were discussing that as well
um there are crimes of uh war crimes
um and then there are crimes of
aggression and for
um Prosecuting the crimes of aggression
we need the international tribunal so
the question is uh which uh organization
is putting up the international tribunal
and I see that the European Union could
be the embodiment and of course other
countries can join because this is
something the war war crimes are crimes
that are committed in Ukraine the crimes
of aggression are the crimes of really
attacking another country and therefore
I think the European Union should have a
leading role in putting together this
International Tribunal
thank you second question Delphi please
would you say or
or maybe you could give your stance on
how should it look like how fast should
it be done and a follow-up question is
like there are loopholes that people can
escape the sanctions from you know
through through the glucose how would
you say the EU has learned from the
previous loopholes and how will they be
tackled in future so we just
um issued and agreed on the eighth
package of sanctions a few days ago
therefore it is important now to
implement it and to create a track
record
and what the loopholes and circumvention
is concerned overall these sanctions are
really biting we see that in the Russian
economy it is absolutely going down the
drain and what we see is by now that our
export Bans are having a very severe
impact on the economy for example
slowing down any kind of production of
high-tech products having an effect on
the military complex that's exactly what
we want it production for example of
automobiles has almost come to a still
stand stand still so these are the
topics that were expected from the
sanctions we have issued the eighth
package of sanctions and we learn from
one package to the next one about
circumvention and loopholes and over and
over are then in the follow-up package
closing those loopholes and
circumventions what we've done for
example in the eighth package that's
very important is that we said in
certain countries if you take European
Goods bring them to third countries and
then bring them to Russia
the person who does that or the entity
who does that will be listed by us so
this is a very strong deterrent to make
sure that we do not have a circumvention
through third countries towards Russia
it is unfortunately all the time we have
the president is expected in Qatar and
thank you for following and thank you
for coming have a nice day thank you
foreign